[Music]
[Applause]
Sean Solsbury former NFL USC quarterback
host of the Shan Solsbury show Sports
Talk 790 in Houston always good to see
you buddy let me start with the
Cowboys okay how much credit do the
Cowboys deserve right now well Dad I
know what meltdown looks like I've
created a few of those in my
life much to the Shaga coaches and
players on the sideline um I where they
are right now I think last night it's a
win you'll take them they're hard to
come by old cliche I'm with you and
listening to what you were talking about
Dan too many big plays and they didn't
hit the quarterback enough last night
but their defense we've seen in the past
is capable of that disruption in the
backfield they're going to need that and
you're right it's for the Cowboys it's
three phases for me Dan up until
December then what am I going to see in
December and then are you a January or
February team because they've proven to
us there December January Team without
the the playoff guts or whatever to get
to February now do I believe Prescott's
in the MVP talk yes and should am I
concerned about half you give up 30 plus
points in a game to uh in December
January you're not you're going to lose
that's not going to happen on a
continuous basis I trust that they're
better but Dan no matter what I don't
care if they run through 4-0 in December
because I give the Cowboys a lot of
credit as well and I think they are not
only formidable but dangerous and
there's feels like there's a different
energy about them right now but come see
me in January because no matter what
happens now home field advantage not
home field advantage they still got to
prove to me that their stones are
dangling in January and if they do that
it's it's it's a it's a then we'll be
talking different they'll get all the
credit because everybody wants to talk
about America's team but there's still
much to prove because I know a lot of
guys who can get to January only a
couple get to February at least at that
position over the last handful of years
dangling Stones man one of my favorite
bands of all time oh oh dude them and uh
well Creed uh dangling
Stones uh Thursday Night Football
Standalone game and lot of penalties
here we we we say this we say this often
you can call a penalty on every play you
don't have to call a penalty on every
play but how do we get through this how
do we sort of find a happy medium where
we want the calls to be right but we
don't want you to be right all the time
in making these calls it slows down the
flow of the game certainly at the end of
the first half that took forever it does
and Dan but let me ask you this in in
this conversation okay so if I tell you
the game's gonna last six minutes
longer but the reason why because three
plays in the game they're going to spend
a little extra time would you be willing
to sacrifice six minutes for the right
play and the right answer me too yes and
see I I I subscribe to this I don't want
to give him any more replay Flags I the
the red flags I mean to to to challenge
the call but I don't understand why
isn't every call a judgment call why
can't you review every call I I I don't
understand if there's a a legal
procedure penalty why can't I review
that if a guy jump too soon I'm willing
to sacrifice eight minutes of my life to
get it right how are we we have this
conversation across the country every
year too many injuries and too many
penalties yet you're never going to be
happy on either side so for me I I am
all for getting it getting it right even
if it takes extra time the problem is
can the referees do we need more
referees not more voices on the field
with referees but more referees who see
what maybe a 60y old can't keep up with
a 25y old I don't know but we are GNA
have human air as long as AI isn't you
know referee in these games I don't know
how to fix it Dan other than I know
every week we see calls that you cannot
miss with the naked eye you just can't
you can't miss it with a naked eye
because if we can I don't want that job
hell I couldn't be a ref I don't want
any part of it but I know this they
probably don't want any part of playing
quarterback either or they don't want
any part of doing what you do because
your expertise uh they're probably
better at my job than I'd be at theirs
but I do know this they're the experts
they get paid the money maybe we got to
make it a full-time gig whatever that
might be but you can't miss these simple
calls and if it takes a few extra
minutes to get it right my concern is
when replay misses it if replay says
it's right you know when well it's too
close to change if it's right change it
I don't know the answer Dan but we're
gonna have this until the end of time
and you and I both know it okay what do
you think of our idea of offensive and
defensive linemen wear mittens therefore
you can't hold well mittens sound so
soft right can you say tough guy gloves
um okay you know what tough guy glov
you're talking about there you go gloves
you mean with like with like this stand
where the four fingers are together and
the the thumb sits by itself yeah like
Ralphie in Christmas story right
okay but those th I could still maybe
get the thumb like a you know like a
lobster and they got to be like
fluorescent so we see yeah I'm not sure
Dan I'm not sure that's gonna help okay
but I'm with you on holding uh but I
don't mind if they hold inside because I
got news for you day and if they
actually did that remember how we preach
player safety but we'll play three days
later on a Thursday like last night did
hey man we care about him the concussion
but we'll see you Thursday because the
Cowboys are going to draw a lot of
people is Dan think about now you think
it's rough on quarterbacks now imagine
not being able to grab Miles Garrett on
the inside of his armpits or Jersey that
you're trying to fiddle around with it
and he's slinging you back into the
quarter our quarterbacks will be dead if
these offensive linemen can't hold but
but I'm with you on the fact that so we
can see it let every how about this Sean
everybody gets to hold offense defensive
linemen get to hold as long as it's
inside the is as long as it's inside
yeah are you okay with that yeah I I
don't have a problem with that I don't
have a like a wrestling match but you
got to do it you can't bear hug him but
within reason hold inside the shoulders
I don't have a problem hey the more the
penalties the marrier like why don't we
just take off all the gear and play play
rugby uh if I would have told you three
months ago that CJ strad and the Texans
would be in the hunt to win the division
maybe a playoff uh Team you would have
said what absolutely not I would have
said growth I had them at six wins when
the season started Dan and if they were
fortunate to get a few breaks and win a
couple late games seven eight would have
been uh demo Ryan and the coach of the
Year talk well now they're sitting at
six and have proven and it's it's
amazing what one guy can do not just the
coach but on the field too as the player
to change that like Joe burrow did in
Cincinnati to almost feel like when he
walks the building like CJ strad you're
expected to win now now when I'm
watching last week Dan on that final
drive I I was guaranteed now I don't
like a fade route to a tight end on
fourth and one but I I almost felt oh
he's going to go down and score CJ
strout so I would have said no now I'm
to the point for the first time in a
long time thinking man if they're within
one score and there's two minutes left
they got a chance Deo has changed we
hear culture used too much but he's
changed the energy and the
accountability in the building and CJ
strout has that feeling I remember John
Elway told me years ago Dan we were
sitting and having a beer at his golf
tournament I said John what is it that
you could be having an average game
which he didn't have very often and then
all of a sudden with 220 220 to go
you're down a score it just kicks in and
you know what he told me I thought I'm
looking for a scientific answer he said
Sean I did it once I did it a second
time and then everybody just thought
well we're gonna do it now John's got
different DNA than the rest of us but
and then they believed in it and this
team now the buzz here Dan every time he
has the ball in his hand he gives you
the best chance to succeed I I I'm
fascinated by the way he's playing uh
his feet everything but it's his ability
to get through through progressions and
have believability that you're begging
for as a rookie and you almost ask for
it he hasn't had to ask for it it's been
heaped upon him and he's he's accepted
it and played his his rear end off aside
from Jaylen Herz I'm not watching a more
poised quarterback poised in the league
than the guy you're watching here in
Houston man alive I can't imagine what
it's going to be like when he actually
learns how to play it's been pretty
fascinating watch but he's this is let's
not forget about Mahomes in there there
is well I I did but I said I didn't say
best I said ability to have poised right
that because right listen I expect
Mahomes to be poised he's been doing it
enough I'm just talking about the
ability where his team you know you got
to carry him last most of the time the
Run game has not been what you want it
to be you're with a make makeshift
offensive line most of us would be
panicked and watching the line at this
stage of his career the Poise that she's
showing is a guy that's been in the
league as long as Mahomes so I think the
Texans you got to find that guy and you
got to find the coach when you start
with those two the whole energy of the
building changes especially when you
have success I would have never thought
it this way and now Dan I think the
loser of this Denver Texans game is g to
have a hard time getting in but the
winner is going to be in a real good
position to continue and and have a
chance to win it especially with the
Texans schedule Sean guilty of name
dropping there guys moner the and he had
a beer with laway and he got invited
to's golf tournament okay I'm going to
throw the flag hey we're throwing the
flag today another penalty I'm going to
charge you 15 for yeah this is my first
my first penalty on your show I didn't
know it was out humble brag remember the
time when you and I were playing and
Kevin James was oh see yeah yeah there
you go see hum
brag I feel like that was more inside
holding I'm gonna let it go that's a
solid drop that's that's holding on the
inside Sean you're good okay all right
you know what I call pick up the flag
we'll pick up the flag that's left
tackle kicking his left leg out to get a
start in the shotgun early okay that's a
is Lan Johnson yes yes Todd wasn't this
the same guy that hung out with had a
Locker on the beach
something I don't listen why why brag
now I mean you know hey it's there you
want me to tell you on Santa mon I mean
listen Dan when you got it you just
don't have to say anything about it plus
that was when I had a full head of hair
flowing locks and the rest of it yeah
they had their locker but you guys will
throw a double flag on me if we talk
about that no no no no no no no I allow
to Humble brag on that that's that you
know what when you said it and I know
you told me the story probably 15 or 20
times 400 times but it's still it's I
mean that's pretty good you made out
with Heather Lair I didn't say that you
did too did no I did not did you kiss
Heather Lair I can neither confirm nor
deny okay so what what constitutes
making out with Heather
La uh French Kiss three oh okay yeah and
parle
Vu listen I I can I can't confirm when
nor I back in 1984 come on we had a you
know what lovely lady fun okay uh we
gave 110% we took it we took it one bite
of our Italian food at the time uh
Before I Let You Go why are the Niners
favored in
Philadelphia I have absolutely no idea
may I couldn't tell you but that's why I
guess they buil casinos and aircond
conditioned hotels I maybe it's the when
did Philadelphia play last Dan when was
their last game was it Sunday or or was
it last Sunday Sunday night was it sun
when did they play when did they when
were they play last I don't have any
idea yeah there you go maybe maybe it's
the energy exert I I have no idea on the
road across the country playing against
Philadelphia who is the best team in
football both quarterbacks are in the
MVP talk I don't know but I'm going to
tell you it's going to take a great
effort to go in there and their MO it'll
be the most hostile environment San
Francisco play plays in and I just am
curious why the world still doesn't
believe that Brock py can play I I I
just don't know why oh he's on a good
team we make that excuse for every
quarterback that is on a good team
that's the object to be on a good team
Brock P's a good player and the last
time they visited there we didn't get
four quarters at him I like Philadelphia
I think this is a preview of the NFC
Championship Game this be the last they
meet Sean it's where you're drafted
that's right if he was a if he was a
third pick of the draft Dan yeah what
would we be saying who they found their
next guy right yes just like you know
Trey Lance if he would have been taken
where Tre Lance was and Tre Lance the
other way around you know we'd be like
oh Tre Lance maybe maybe down the road
he could be a backup quarterback uh Dak
Prescott you know we you know where
you're drafted you're labeled it's like
the stigma you can't be that good you
know right because you weren't dra Miss
yes they but those experts Miss they
miss a lot of times and here's a guy now
we're talking about Fran you're exactly
right if you put him up seven rounds and
he was the eighth pick of the draft we'd
be talking about MVP they found their
future he's a franchise guy it's almost
as if people are waiting for him to fail
because no way the seventh pick of the
draft can be this good yeah or the
seventh round pick the last pick of the
draft so I think this gonna be a hell of
a game maybe it's the game of the
weekend but this won't be the last time
I don't think we see these two in the
NFC playoffs good to talk to you have a
good weekend buddy I can it's great to
talk to you too and I'll never let you
know about heatherlock you already have
let me know you already told me I'll
text you with real information no you
already Sean Salsbury former NFL
quarterback see you buddy Sean Salsbury
show Sports Talk 790 in Houston